Lucia: 就是做可行性研究报告
Lucia: Is to create a feasibility study report.
Lucia: 其中包括我们的预算
Lucia: Including our budget.
Alice: 我们的预算是不是告急了
Alice: Is our budget running low?
Lucia: 是不是告急了
Lucia: Is it running low?
Jake: 每人500吧
Jake: 500 per person.
Tasha: 什么东西每人500
Tasha: What's 500 per person?
Jake: 每人500的那个房间对吧
Jake: 500 per person for the room, right?
Alice: 啊不是我说我说我们总体的
Alice: Ah no, I mean our overall budget.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 总体我们我们还花什么钱吗
Jake: Overall, what else are we spending money on?
Katrina:  我们其实主要就吃吃喝喝花了点钱
Katrina: Mostly we just spent money on food and drinks.
Lucia: 我们恩格尔系数超高
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is super high.
Katrina:  哈哈哈确实
Katrina: Hahaha, indeed.
Jake: 全是身份这个没办法
Jake: It's all about status, we can't help it.
Lucia: 人是铁饭是钢嘛哈哈哈
Lucia: People need food as much as iron needs steel, hahaha.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Exactly.
Tasha: 我看下附近租了好多都是哈利波特的
Tasha: I see a lot of Harry Potter rentals nearby.
Alice: 因为这有那啥对哦
Alice: Because there's, you know, that thing.
Katrina:  就我们附近的一个公园
Katrina: Like the park near us.
Katrina:  哎就是去看大爷遛弯
Katrina: Oh, where we watch the old folks take walks.
Jake: 就这些都是奢侈品项目里边的奢侈品
Jake: All of these are luxury items within luxury projects.
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All of these.
Katrina:  昨天30度今天20度
Katrina: Yesterday was 30 degrees, today it's 20 degrees.
Tasha: 好像就那一家可以
Tasha: Seems like only that one place is available.
Lucia: 如果实在不行也可以
Lucia: If it's really not possible, that's fine too.
Lucia: 就是那种那种休闲一点的服装
Lucia: We can go for more casual attire.
Katrina:  嗯北京特别大
Katrina: Hmm, Beijing is really big.
Lucia: 然后就是稍微便宜点的那种小小上衣
Lucia: And then there are those slightly cheaper small tops.
Lucia: 牛仔裤或者假的
Lucia: Jeans or fake ones.
Lucia: 当然现在关键是大家好像没有
Lucia: But now the main issue is that we don't seem to have...
Lucia: 就是就是我们自己的衣服凑
Lucia: I mean, we can't gather our own clothes.
Lucia: 凑不出来
Lucia: Can't gather them.
Lucia: 风格统一的一套否则的话也就
Lucia: A uniform style set, otherwise, we could just...
Lucia: 是用自己的衣服也行
Lucia: Use our own clothes.
Lucia: 像我们之前上课的时候
Lucia: Like when we had classes before.
Lucia: 就最后汇报表演
Lucia: The final performance report.
Lucia: 就是我们老师就是挑的那种
Lucia: Our teacher picked those...
Lucia: 就是大概三四十块钱的那种小上衣
Lucia: Tops that cost around 30 or 40 yuan.
Lucia: 然后底下一个五六十的那种裤子
Lucia: And pants that cost about 50 or 60 yuan.
Lucia: 只不过他可能没有打过风格
Lucia: Although they might not have hit the style.
Lucia: 就那种偏稍微休闲一点的风格
Lucia: They were more of a slightly casual style.
Tasha: 永乐店
Tasha: Yongledian.
Tasha: 不知道啊搜一搜
Tasha: Not sure, let's search it.
Jake: 高德在国内是很常用吗
Jake: Is Gaode widely used in China?
Jake: 嗯就是比百度地图要好
Jake: Hmm, it's better than Baidu Maps.
Katrina:  我觉得比百度好用在界面流畅上
Katrina: I think it's better than Baidu in terms of interface smoothness.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Tasha: 好远啊在哪
Tasha: So far, where is it?
Jake: 在哪好远多远
Jake: Where is it? How far?
Jake: 18公里算了
Jake: 18 kilometers, forget it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  真郊区
Katrina: Really suburban.
Jake: 通州还要再开
Jake: You have to drive another 18 kilometers in Tongzhou.
Jake: 18公里
Jake: 18 kilometers.
Katrina:  对通州还要开18公里走
Katrina: Yes, you need to drive another 18 kilometers in Tongzhou.
Shure: 走外卖到了
Shure: Let's go, the food delivery has arrived.
Jake: 走吃饺子吧
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子
Shure: 去楼上吃对走吧
Shure: Let's go upstairs to eat, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 需要拼不对
Alice: Need to piece it together.
Alice: 需要醋那个
Alice: Need vinegar for that.
Jake: 那哎
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 要醋要带
Jake: You need to bring vinegar.
Jake: 带上去带上去
Jake: Bring it up.
Alice: 哦那什么时候录
Alice: Oh, when are we recording?
Alice: 哎不对导数据呢
Alice: Oh no, importing data.
Alice: 吃完OK哎呀
Alice: Done eating, okay.
Shure: 去上个厕所
Shure: Going to the bathroom.
Jake: 吃饺子
Jake: Eating dumplings.
Katrina:  我们还包饺子
Katrina: We're also making dumplings.
Jake: 哈哈哈好主意
Jake: Hahaha good idea.
Jake: 我们包个饺子吧
Jake: Let's make some dumplings.
Alice: 哈哈哈真的吗
Alice: Hahaha really?
Jake: 不不不这个太麻烦了
Jake: No no no, that's too troublesome.
Jake: 我们没有什么精力包饺子
Jake: We don't have the energy to make dumplings.
Katrina:  我们很我们在完成最后一天的任务已经够呛
Katrina: We're already struggling to complete the last day's tasks.
Katrina:  哈哈上楼
Katrina: Haha, let's go upstairs.
Jake: 对时间还挺紧的
Jake: Yeah, time is tight.
Katrina:  还要装饰房间
Katrina: We still need to decorate the room.
Katrina:  还要排舞啊
Katrina: And rehearse the dance.
Katrina:  其实还蛮多
Katrina: Actually, there's a lot to do.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 有人一起上楼吗
Alice: Is anyone coming upstairs with me?
Katrina:  有有有
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 嚯这这一身哈利波特吗
Jake: Whoa, is this a Harry Potter costume?
Tasha: 真的吗已经换装了
Tasha: Really? Already changed?
Alice: 嗯来了一个
Alice: Hmm, here comes one.
Jake: 我刚刚远远一看
Jake: I just saw from afar.
Jake: 我觉得这服装到底啥意思啊
Jake: I was wondering what this costume means.
Jake: 这个啊
Jake: This one, huh?
Katrina:  我以为你说来了谁
Katrina: I thought you were saying someone arrived.
Jake: 刚刚他是
Jake: Just now, he was...
Jake: 就是过来的时候他的那个粉色是
Jake: When he came over, the pink part was...
Jake: 大概到一半就是黑的
Jake: About halfway, it was black.
Jake: 粉的就是就你这个服装很好看
Jake: The pink part, just like this, your costume looks great.
Jake: 走吃饭去
Jake: Let's go eat.
Jake: 吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina:  走吧上楼去
Katrina: Let's go upstairs.
Katrina:  拿瓶醋吧
Katrina: Grab a bottle of vinegar.
Alice: 你最爱的醋
Alice: Your favorite vinegar.
Alice: 上楼吧
Alice: Let's go upstairs.
Jake: 你们上楼收拾收拾
Jake: You guys go upstairs and tidy up.
Jake: 然后把这边
Jake: And then here...
Jake: 空下来我就
Jake: Once it's cleared, I'll...
Jake: 哦是什么
Jake: Oh, what is it?
Jake: 我我我就测一个内参
Jake: I'm just gonna measure an internal parameter.
Jake: 我测个外参
Jake: I'll measure an external parameter.
Katrina:  没人打扫
Katrina: No one's cleaning up.
Katrina:  想打扫就打扫
Katrina: If you want to clean, just clean.
Katrina:  我今天早上起来洗个澡
Katrina: I got up this morning and took a shower.
Jake: 开了一个
Jake: Started one.
Alice: 等我们结束了之后我去找你玩吧
Alice: How about after we're done, I'll come play with you?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Katrina:  上次上次帮他给女朋友挑礼物来着
Katrina: Last time, last time I helped him pick out a gift for his girlfriend.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Tasha: 好贵啊他家
Tasha: It's so expensive at his place.
Alice:还给了糖酸
Alice: They even gave us some sweet garlic.
Alice: 这不是糖蒜
Alice: This isn't sweet garlic.
Alice: 这是腊八蒜
Alice: This is Laba garlic.
Lucia: 哦我去拿个线
Lucia: Oh, I'll go get a cable.
Lucia: 我把我的线
Lucia: I'll get my cable.
Katrina:  这是啥呀
Katrina: What is this?
Alice: 啊腊八蒜哦
Alice: Ah, it's Laba garlic.
Tasha: 不知道啊
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure:  吃饺子
Shure: Eat dumplings.
Shure:  这是什么腊八蒜
Shure: What kind of Laba garlic is this?
Shure:  你刚才在哼什么
Shure: What were you humming just now?
Katrina:  哎我刚哼的这首歌叫什么来着
Katrina: Hey, what was the name of the song I was humming just now?
Shure:  你哼的啥
Shure: What were you humming?
Shure:  你再哼一遍
Shure: Hum it again.
Katrina:  忘了
Katrina: Forgot.
Katrina:  7秒钟的记忆
Katrina: Seven-second memory.
Shure: 哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da.
Katrina:  是告五人的
Katrina: It's by Accusefive.
Shure:  没有这个印象
Shure: I don't remember that.
Shure:  霉霉发新专了
Shure: Taylor Swift released a new album.
Shure:  已经不是霉粉了
Shure: I'm not a Swiftie anymore.
Shure:  那你说你上一张专辑你你最爱听
Shure: So tell me, which song from her last album is your favorite?
其他人：上一张一首没听
Others: Haven't listened to a single song from the last album.
Shure:  哈哈哈什么东西
Shure: Haha, what the heck?
Shure:  你看这种又当又立这种
Shure: Look at you being all high and mighty.
其他人：能不能从现在开始回归吗
Others: Can we just start over from now?
其他人：不喜欢上一张专辑
Katrina:  倒点醋
Katrina: Pour some vinegar.
其他人：卧槽我跟你说
Others: Oh my god, let me tell you.
其他人：我演唱会的时候放到发上来
Others: I'll post it during my concert.
其他人：你的时候我吃
Others: I'll be eating during yours.
其他人：  在那休息了
Others: Resting there.
Shure:  你演唱会你不是把票卖了吗
Shure: Didn't you sell your concert tickets?
其他人：  我没卖啊卖了我去新加坡干嘛
Others: No, I didn't sell them. Why would I go to Singapore if I did?
Katrina:  这是啥
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  啊嗨
Shure: Ah, hey.
Shure:  你摸到霉霉大腿了吗
Shure: Did you touch Taylor Swift's thigh?
其他人：霉霉离我就10米
Others: She was just 10 meters away from me.
其他人：要是再中国我肯定冲上去摸了新加坡不太敢
Others: If it were in China, I would have rushed up to touch her. But in Singapore, I didn't dare.
Shure:  法律比较严格是吧
Shure: The laws are stricter, right?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：怕被鞭刑
Others: Afraid of getting whipped.
Katrina:  这是韭菜饼是吧
Katrina: Is this a chive pancake?
Jake: 是吧摸什么
Jake: Yeah, what are you touching?
其他人：我里霉霉最近就10米我冲到第一排
Others: I was just 10 meters away from Taylor Swift. I rushed to the front row.
Katrina:  那票多少钱
Katrina: How much was the ticket?
Katrina:  前排
Katrina: The front row ticket.
Shure:  差一点成功虽然味可能不太一样
Shure: Almost succeeded, but the taste might be different.
其他人：票钱就不要在问了有点悲惨的故事
Others: Don't ask about the ticket price, it's a sad story.
Shure:  但是差不多差不多
Shure: But it's close enough.
Jake: 那就更要问了
Jake: Then we should definitely ask.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：有点悲惨的故事
Others: It's a sad story.
Lucia: 你也满神奇的
Lucia: You're quite magical.
Katrina:  你可以去参加那个6句话的故事
Katrina: You could join that six-word story thing.
其他人：那六句话很多是假的
Others: Many of those six-word stories are fake.
Katrina:  6句话感觉你都说不完了
Katrina: Feels like you can't finish in six words.
其他人：给校长提烟是不可能的
Others: It's impossible to give the principal cigarettes.
Shure:  反正吃完12点了
Shure: Anyway, it's past midnight after eating.
Katrina:  嘉和一品
Katrina: Jiahe Yipin.
Shure:  还行不是还有其他的
Shure: It's okay, there are other things.
Katrina:  成了
Katrina: Done.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  然后还买少了呢趟
Shure: And I bought less this time.
Shure:  on go on
Shure: On go on.
Shure:  谁到了
Shure: Who arrived?
Lucia: 这个谁要碗吗
Lucia: Does anyone need a bowl?
Katrina:  拿不拿都行
Katrina: It's fine either way.
Lucia: 要碗吗
Lucia: Need a bowl?
Katrina:  我自己有了
Katrina: I got it myself.
Lucia: 这个好像昨天洗过
Lucia: This one seems like it was washed yesterday.
Shure:  你拉拉倒
Shure: Just give it up.
Shure:  拉倒吧拉倒吧拉倒吧
Shure: Give it up, give it up, give it up.
Shure:  呵呵你还整
Shure: Haha, and you still try.
Lucia: 抹布比碗还油
Lucia: The rag is greasier than the bowl.
Shure:  你长得跟跟跟哎呀
Shure: You look like... oh well.
Shure:  行完完完再说
Shure: Alright, we'll talk about it later.
Shure:  不着急不着急
Shure: No rush, no rush.
Alice:你那个是什么材质
Alice: What's that made of?
Alice: 呃下边那个
Alice: Uh, the one at the bottom.
其他人：我也不知道
Others: I don't know either.
Alice: 这是一串的
Alice: This is a whole string.
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  笑的跟那个老鼠一样哈哈
Katrina: You're laughing like a mouse, haha.
Shure:  哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：这个好像就是那种普通的
Others: This seems to be just the usual type.
Alice: 像虎精又不太像虎
Alice: Looks like a tiger spirit but not quite.
Jake: 开吃
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake: 缺人是吧
Jake: We're missing someone, right?
Tasha: 吧
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
Lucia: 碗是死的人是活的
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 我们也可以让碗活起来
Jake: We can also make the bowl come alive.
Jake: 全是青草全是草
Jake: It's all grass, all grass.
Jake: 一桌子草
Jake: A table full of grass.
Jake: 每桌都对
Jake: Every table, right?
其他人：全是素馅
Others: It's all veggie stuffing.
Jake: 哈哈知道为什么吗
Jake: Haha, do you know why?
Jake: 就今天是一个节气
Jake: Because today is a solar term.
其他人：谷雨
Others: Grain Rain.
Jake: 嗯你怎么知道的我哈哈
Jake: Yeah, how did you know that? Haha.
其他人：我刷到的公众号，但是我不知道谷雨是干嘛的
Jake: 谷雨是干嘛的
Jake: What is Grain Rain for?
Jake: 谷雨是种种地
Jake: Grain Rain is for planting.
Jake: 嗯要下雨了
Jake: Hmm, it's going to rain.
Alice: 那是清明前后
Alice: That's around Qingming.
Alice: 种瓜点豆
Alice: Planting melons and beans.
Jake: 哦种东西
Jake: Oh, planting things.
其他人：所以谷雨就要吃菜
Others: So Gu Yu is going to eat vegetables.
Alice: 春菜
Alice: Spring vegetables.
Jake:这大概是有一批菜初长
Jake: This is probably when a batch of vegetables first grows.
Jake: 长完了可以吃了应该
Jake: Once they are fully grown, you can eat them.
Alice: 嗯主要是香椿
Alice: Yes, mainly Chinese toon.
Alice: 香椿在谷雨之后就木质了
Alice: Chinese toon becomes woody after Gu Yu.
其他人：你们还在录吗
Others: Are you guys still recording?
Jake: 这什么馅的
Jake: What's the filling?
Jake: 他有两种馅
Jake: There are two kinds of fillings.
其他人：这好像是韭菜
Others: This one seems to be chives.
Alice: 韭菜鸡蛋
Alice: Chive and egg.
Jake: 韭菜鸡蛋和肉
Jake: Chive and egg and meat.
Katrina:  有肉的
Katrina: There's meat.
Jake: 那就是
Jake: So it's...
Jake: 什么芹菜
Jake: Celery?
Katrina:  把醋倒这了
Katrina: Pour the vinegar here.
Jake: 要醋有芹菜吗这里面
Jake: Do we need vinegar with celery in it?
Jake: 还是白菜啊
Jake: Or is it cabbage?
Katrina: 这衣服是是租还是买
Katrina:  你给个预算然后我们办事
Katrina: You give us a budget, and we'll handle it.
Lucia: 要我给你出个预算研究报告
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, hahaha.
Lucia: 那你也给个预算然后再研究研究
Lucia: Then you give a budget and we'll discuss it.
Jake: 我我我估一下
Jake: I'll estimate it.
Jake: 我算一算现在是什么
Jake: I'll calculate what it is now.
Jake: 如果是买的话最便宜是多少
Jake: If we buy, what's the cheapest?
Tasha: 不对 44
Tasha: No, it's 44.
Tasha: 买个上衣
Tasha: Buy a top.
Tasha: 算了吧我现在看到了有一个
Tasha: Never mind, I see there's one for...
Tasha: 全部都是25块钱一套
Tasha: Everything is 25 yuan per set.
Jake: 什么东西啊25块钱
Jake: What's 25 yuan?
Tasha: 你要看吗
Tasha: Do you want to see it?
Jake: 没事
Jake: No, it's fine.
Lucia: 人要还喝可乐吗
Lucia: Does anyone still want to drink cola?
Jake: 喝我来喝
Jake: I'll drink it.
Jake: 我先把这是我的咖啡
Jake: I'll finish my coffee first.
Jake: 我先把咖啡喝了
Jake: I'll drink my coffee first.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 自己看着办吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Just figure it out yourself, hahaha.
Tasha: 您就是老板
Tasha: You are the boss.
Tasha: 动都不动
Tasha: Not moving at all.
Jake: 是老板就说你看着办吧
Jake: If you're the boss, just say "handle it yourself."
Jake: 呵呵这是谢谢您
Jake: Haha, this is thank you.
Jake:这啥呀我去
Jake: What is this, oh my.
Jake: 这是哪翻来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Tasha: 但是这个是长沙的
Tasha: But this one is from Changsha.
Tasha: 所以他要涂三天
Tasha: So it needs to be applied for three days.
Tasha: 那三天就是
Tasha: That means three days.
Tasha: 呃3.3是吧
Tasha: Uh, 3.3 right?
Lucia: 那衣服到不了三天第一天到第二天用第三天退还
Lucia: That dress won't last three days, use it on the first and second day, return it on the third day.
Tasha: 嗯对所以他其实是25块钱好像
Tasha: Yeah, so actually it's about 25 bucks, I think.
Tasha: 我再看看他是这么写的吧
Tasha: Let me check how it's written.
Tasha: 你看18R 3天
Tasha: Look, 18R for three days.
Jake: 好好好这个预算可以
Jake: Okay, this budget works.
Jake: 这个远远没到预算
Jake: This is way under budget.
Jake: 哈哈其实我也不知道预算多少
Jake: Haha, actually, I don't even know the budget.
Jake: 但是那1,000的话肯定过分了
Jake: But if it's 1,000, that's definitely too much.
Jake: 500以上肯定多
Jake: Anything over 500 is too much.
Katrina:  确实只穿一次
Katrina: True, it's only worn once.
Tasha: 但是这个的话就是在长沙
Tasha: But for this one, it's in Changsha.
Tasha: 他要租的话可能就要三天左右
Tasha: If he wants to rent it, it might be around three days.
Tasha: 只有这一套他是18
Tasha: There's only this one set, it's 18.
Tasha: 还有这种的他好像都是48
Tasha: And this type seems to be 48.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Not sure.
Tasha: 是吧一套两套
Tasha: Right, one or two sets.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 但是如果是这家店的话他就在通州
Tasha: But if it's from this store, it's in Tongzhou.
Tasha: 嗯但他们家好像比较贵
Tasha: Yeah, but their stuff seems more expensive.
Tasha: 他说点购买就可以知道
Tasha: He said click purchase to know.
Tasha: 第一套是25块钱
Tasha: The first set is 25 bucks.
Tasha: 第二套就要2550358045403520
Tasha: The second set goes up to 2550358045403520.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 一人50左右吧行吧
Jake: About 50 bucks per person, okay?
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Jake: 可可行吗
Jake: Is it doable?
Lucia: 可行应该是可行
Lucia: It should be doable.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Yeah, it's fine.
Katrina:  但是哈利波特衣服一天都只要50块
Katrina: But Harry Potter costumes only cost 50 bucks a day.
Lucia: 但是我最好是能
Lucia: But I'd prefer if we could...
Lucia: 我们能在附近找到一个实体店租哦
Lucia: We can find a physical store nearby to rent from.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 因为寄过来的话有一个稍微有点慢
Lucia: Because if it's shipped, it might be a bit slow.
Tasha: 但是那个的话还挺挺远
Tasha: But that one is actually quite far.
Jake: 没亮
Jake: It's not lit.
Tasha: 对挺远的
Tasha: Yeah, it's quite far.
Tasha: 然后25块钱一套那家他
Tasha: And that place charges 25 bucks per set.
Tasha: 居然连鞋子都配
Tasha: They even include shoes.
Tasha: 配饰也都配
Tasha: And accessories too.
Katrina:  这么专业啊
Katrina: So professional.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure:  每次谢运中一来就
Shure: Every time Xie Yunzong comes,
Shure:  咱们就开始练团是吧
Shure: We start practicing as a group, right?
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
其他人：我靠我这时间来的太不巧了
Others: Oh man, my timing is so off.
Jake: 哈哈哈我有筷子
Jake: Hahaha, I've got chopsticks.
Katrina:  没有餐具了吗
Katrina: No utensils left?
Jake: 给俩勺子可以
Jake: Two spoons will do.
Shure:  别别别别
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  咱又不是没筷子
Shure: It's not like we don't have chopsticks.
Alice: 那个柜子里好多筷子
Alice: There are plenty of chopsticks in that cabinet.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  给我倒一点
Shure: Pour me a little.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Alice: 这是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Is this celery leaf?
Shure:  我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  香椿
Shure: It's Chinese toon.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one?
Alice: 这不是香椿吧
Alice: This isn't Chinese toon, right?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice: 不像香椿
Alice: Doesn't look like Chinese toon.
Tasha: 们都这么多鸡蛋了
Tasha: We already have so many eggs.
Tasha: 还要买个打鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Do we really need to buy an egg beater?
Lucia: 就是只要我在家就敢吃炒蛋哈哈
Lucia: As long as I'm home, I can eat scrambled eggs, haha.
Lucia: 笑话好冷
Lucia: That joke was so lame.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈反射弧有点慢
Shure: Hahaha, my reaction was a bit slow.
Lucia: 不是真不是我要逼迫大家吃的
Lucia: No, really, I'm not forcing everyone to eat.
其他人：这个炒鸡杂好吃
Others: This stir-fried chicken giblets is delicious.
Lucia: 不是这些不是我点的
Lucia: These weren't ordered by me.
Lucia: 不要误会
Lucia: Don't get the wrong idea.
Lucia: 哎这啥情况
Lucia: Hey, what's going on?
Lucia: 我明天又掉线了
Lucia: I got disconnected again tomorrow.
Lucia: 又掉线了
Lucia: Disconnected again.
Jake: 又掉线了
Jake: Disconnected again.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 那就再连上吧
Jake: Then reconnect it.
Lucia: 但他应该有电
Lucia: But it should have power.
Lucia: 那为啥
Lucia: Then why...
Alice: 杨老板这个是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Jake, are these celery leaves?
Jake: 呃我看一下菜单
Jake: Uh, let me check the menu.
Lucia: 新鲜
Lucia: Fresh.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 今天是试做
Lucia: Today is a test run.
Jake: 呃这应该就是香椿苗炒鸡蛋
Jake: Uh, this should be fried eggs with Chinese toon sprouts.
Alice: 这个是香椿苗
Alice: These are Chinese toon sprouts.
Jake: 那就是叫它叫老味道蒸菜
Jake: So let's call it the traditional steamed dish.
Jake: 我不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is.
Jake: 我看一下啊
Jake: Let me check.
Jake: 蒿子杆
Jake: Mugwort stems.
Lucia: 我想夹一个那个蛋
Lucia: I want to grab one of those eggs.
Tasha: 好油啊
Tasha: So oily.
Lucia: 这他是锅贴吗
Lucia: Is this a potsticker?
Shure:  差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
Tasha: 哦下面还有层嗯
Tasha: Oh, there's another layer underneath, hmm.
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this thing is called a potsticker.
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: Then what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: Let me try it.
其他人：像什么香河肉饼那种
Others: Like those stuffed meat pies.
Alice: 为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why is no one eating the pickled garlic?
Shure:  我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat the sweet garlic.
Shure:  但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not the pickled garlic.
Alice: 为啥
Alice: Why?
Katrina:  少忽悠我
Katrina: Stop fooling me.
其他人：这玩意不是糖蒜吗
Others: Isn't this sweet garlic?
Shure:  不是腊八蒜
Shure: Not pickled garlic.
Alice: 腊八蒜
Alice: Pickled garlic.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic has skin.
Jake: 那是什么蒜
Jake: Then what kind of garlic is it?
Jake: 腊八蒜
Jake: Laba garlic.
Shure:  腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic is basically cooked garlic.
Shure:  那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When making sweet garlic, you use fresh garlic.
Shure:  就是那种
Shure: It's that kind.
Shure:  没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: The kind that hasn't been dried.
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: Looks like a pancake.
Jake: 早餐10块
Jake: Breakfast for 10 yuan.
Jake: 饼
Jake: Pancake.
Jake: 撕了吧
Jake: Tear it.
Jake: 就在这撕了吧
Jake: Tear it right here.
Jake: 就在这撕掉
Jake: Tear it off here.
Jake: 看看怎么撕
Jake: Let's see how to tear it.
Shure:  撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Jake: 撕饼
Jake: Tear the pancake.
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also Chinese toon?
Alice: 这个是茴香的啊
Alice: This is fennel.
Jake: 撕完了哎
Jake: Finished tearing.
Jake: 没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not done yet, there's one more.
Jake: 自行认领
Jake: Claim it yourself.
Katrina:  我觉得吃两个就吃饱了
Katrina: I think eating two would be enough.
Jake: 你说8个
Jake: You said 8.
其他人：你今天早上干什么
Others: What did you do this morning?
Katrina:  今天早上那个
Katrina: This morning...
Alice:你要那个馅的吗我给你夹一个
Alice: Do you want that filling? I can get one for you.
Katrina:  烤面包大厨的感觉
Katrina: Feels like a toast chef.
Tasha: 嗯不来吧那个馅有点辣感觉不知道什么东西
Tasha: Hmm, no, that filling seems a bit spicy, not sure what it is.
Katrina:  黄油面包
Katrina: Butter toast.
Shure:  昨天没吃到
Shure: Didn't get to eat it yesterday.
Shure:  我的我的
Shure: My bad.
Shure:  我的肉
Shure: My meat.
Shure:  虽然不是我烤的吧
Shure: Although I didn't roast it myself.
Shure:  你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You should feel sad.
Jake: 我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish roasting?
Jake: 9点半10点半
Jake: 9:30 or 10:30?
Alice: 10点半
Alice: 10:30.
Jake: 10点半烤完
Jake: Finished roasting at 10:30.
Alice:快12点吧
Alice: Almost 12.
Alice: 对就是
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Jake: 肯定烤上
Jake: Definitely roasted.
Jake: 什么时候烤上呢
Jake: When are we going to start grilling?
Jake: 还不知道
Jake: I still don't know.
Katrina:  搞碳搞了半天
Katrina: We've been working on the charcoal for ages.
Katrina:  我看看拍照时间
Katrina: Let me check the photo times.
Alice: 每根头发丝都裹裹满了
Alice: Every single hair is covered with the smell.
Alice: 那个烟的味道
Alice: That smoke smell.
Katrina:  真的是所以必须要洗到洗
Katrina: Yeah, that's why we have to wash thoroughly.
Shure:  昨天晚上我还倒头就睡了
Shure: Last night I just fell asleep immediately.
Shure:  我靠昨天晚上
Shure: Damn, last night...
Shure:  躺那躺一会
Shure: I laid down for a bit...
Shure:  然后就着了
Shure: And then I was out.
其他人：那一天朋友圈回复
Others: That day, the replies on social media...
Jake: 谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
其他人：打平了最后点球皇马赢了
Others: It was a tie, but Real Madrid won in the penalty shootout.
其他人：还好我没看
Others: Good thing I didn't watch.
Jake: 是吧你
Jake: Right, you...
Jake: 你是曼城球迷
Jake: You're a Manchester City fan.
Jake: 哈兰德
Jake: Haaland.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester.
其他人：只有我是姆巴佩的球
Others: I'm the only Mbappe fan.
其他人：所以我很期待姆巴佩打皇马
Others: So I'm really looking forward to Mbappe playing against Real Madrid.
其他人：因为姆巴佩马上要去皇马了
Others: Because Mbappe is about to join Real Madrid.
Lucia: 他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
Jake: 打巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did they beat Paris?
Jake: 就是要打皇马
Jake: They're going to play Real Madrid.
其他人：赢了
Others: They won.
其他人：马上还要打多特
Others: Next, they have to play Dortmund.
其他人： 然后皇马打多特蒙德
Others: Then Real Madrid will play Dortmund.
其他人： 皇马打拜仁
Others: Real Madrid will play Bayern.
其他人：大巴黎打多特
Others: Paris will play Dortmund.
Jake: 我以前都不知道
Jake: I didn't know before...
Jake: 达瓦尼自从我做这个和这个
Jake: Davani, ever since I started doing this and that...
其他人：啊
Others: Ah...
Jake: 啊就这个是我们
Jake: Ah, so this is us...
Jake: 我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper.
Jake: 他态度比较
Jake: His attitude is quite...
Jake: 这个叫叫panelbig
Jake: This is called "panelbig."
其他人：确实你这个大巴黎一看就是大巴黎
Others: Indeed, your Paris is obviously Paris.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 是80年代TSG
Jake: It's the TSG from the 80s.
Jake: 就是大巴黎的那个logo
Jake: It's the logo of Paris Saint-Germain.
Jake: 嗯然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Hmm, then we modified it a bit.
Jake: 改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: Changed it to our segmented version.
Jake: 就它是一个情景分割
Jake: It's a situational segmentation.
Jake: 嗯一看是青年分支
Jake: Hmm, you can see it's a youth branch.
Jake: 就就就割出来的这个东西
Jake: Just this thing segmented out.
Shure:  所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So is it really related to Paris Saint-Germain?
Jake: 简称是就是PSG啊
Jake: The abbreviation is PSG.
Jake: 就硬凑一个简称
Jake: We just forced an abbreviation.
Shure:  就是正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: So the abbreviation is the same, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 就是先出了这个名字
Jake: We came up with the name first.
Jake: 然后简称PSG
Jake: Then the abbreviation was PSG.
Jake: 然后我上网一搜
Jake: Then I searched online.
Jake: 我靠是个球队
Jake: Turns out it's a football team.
Jake: 哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I found out.
Lucia: 巴黎圣日耳曼
Lucia: Paris Saint-Germain.
Shure:  大巴黎他不止有球队
Shure: Paris Saint-Germain has more than just a football team.
Shure:  还有那个电竞的队伍嗯
Shure: They also have an esports team, hmm.
Shure:  吃困了
Shure: Feeling sleepy after eating.
Shure:  吃完就想睡
Shure: Want to sleep after eating.
Shure:  睡醒了就饿
Shure: Hungry after waking up.
Shure:  饿完就想吃
Shure: Want to eat after being hungry.
Shure:  感觉人生已经
Shure: Feels like life is just...
Jake: 对这才是生活
Jake: Yeah, that's life.
Jake: 一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: That's how life should be.
Jake: 跟里面夹了很多戏
Jake: Filled with so much drama.
Jake: 太那个了
Jake: It's too much.
Shure:  不真实我们
Shure: It's not realistic for us.
其他人：你在床上躺一天
Others: You lie in bed all day.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：像只蛆一样的躺一天
Others: Like a maggot lying all day.
其他人：你应该给我个300
Others: You should give me 300 bucks.
其他人：哈哈哈我靠
Others: Haha, damn.
Shure:  我靠我让你看我在床上躺着
Shure: Damn, I let you watch me lying in bed.
其他人：你都是看天花板
Others: You just stare at the ceiling.
其他人：我又看不到你
Others: I can't even see you.
Shure:  那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Then I'll put my glasses here.
Shure:  然后让他拍
Shure: And let him take a picture.
Shure:  我躺着就是让他
Shure: I was just lying down to let him
Jake: 那为什么会眼镜
Jake: Then why did you have glasses
Shure:  人类是一个草履虫
Shure: Humans are like paramecia
Shure:  只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: They can only perform simple life activities
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, help me
Shure:  感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I think I've eaten enough
Shure:  我好饿啵啵
Shure: I'm so hungry, Bobo
Shure:  呸我好好饱
Shure: Oops, I meant I'm so full
其他人：该睡了
Others: It's time to sleep
Jake: 谢斌竹什么时候答辩
Jake: When is Xie Binzhu's defense?
Jake: 模拟答辩
Jake: The mock defense
Katrina:  这跟导师有关
Katrina: That depends on the advisor
Katrina:  我以为是学员
Katrina: I thought it was up to the student
Jake: 就学院要求
Jake: It's a requirement by the school
Jake: 但是导师不管
Jake: But the advisor doesn't care
其他人：但是应该是给我打最高分
Others: But I should get the highest score
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：应为他前几次都没看过最高分
Others: Because he never gave the highest score before
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where can you find such an advisor?
其他人：然后之前
Others: And then before
其他人：他问了一下
Others: He asked once
其他人：就我的导师是我老板
Others: My advisor is my boss
其他人：他
Others: He
其他人：然后他就那个刮了一个导师
Others: Then he removed an advisor
其他人：然后他问了一个老板
Others: And then he asked a boss
其他人：我说我要不要去加他微信啊
Others: I asked if I should add him on WeChat
其他人：要不要搞
Others: Should I do it
其他人：他说以后不烦他尽量别烦他
Jake: 反他就扣分
Jake: Otherwise, he'll deduct points
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  你只要跟我说一句话我就给你扣一分
Shure: If you just say one word to me, I'll deduct one point
其他人：我现在没和他讲过一句话
Others: I haven't spoken a word to him so far
Jake: 准备满分准备满分
Jake: Get ready for a perfect score
Jake: 准备满分
其他人：一开始说过一次
Others: I said something once at the beginning
其他人：最开始给他发了邮件
Others: I sent him an email at the start
其他人：他回我一切信息请不要联系我
Others: He replied, "Please don't contact me for anything"
其他人：联系男老师就行
Others: Just contact the male teacher
Shure:  男老师是什么东西
Shure: What's a male teacher?
其他人：就是张晨
Others: It's Zhang Chen
其他人：嗯然后就24号叫
Others: Hmm, then submit on the 24th.
Shure:  嗯 24号叫final report
Shure: Yeah, the 24th is the final report.
Shure:  30号
Shure: The 30th.
其他人：中间没了
Others: Nothing in between.
Shure:  没有24号
Shure: There's no 24th.
Shure:  就是所有周边材料
Shure: Just all the surrounding materials.
Shure:  加上那个那什么都要交
Shure: Plus everything else needs to be submitted.
其他人：原来那个是刘帅的
Others: That was Choiszt's.
Shure:  那是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: That's his brother.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  你drop的写多少了
Shure: How many pages have you written for the drop?
其他人： 我drop就写了19页
Others: I just wrote 19 pages for the drop.
Jake: 我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: I forgot to submit my initial report back in the day.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 对对恶劣伪报扣了10%
Jake: Yeah, I got a 10% deduction for false reporting.
其他人：你要搞那个什么
Others: You need to deal with that thing.
Jake: 最后90
Jake: The final 90.
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yeah, the final 90.
其他人：为什么是因为你早生就好
Others: Why? Because you were born early?
其他人：是因为你
Others: Because you...
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Shure:  你这你就是你
Shure: It's you, it's just you.
Shure:  这孩子不会说话
Shure: This kid can't talk properly.
Shure:  领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader already hinted at it.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎呦我的
Shure: Hahaha oh my.
Shure:  妈呀这是为什么
Shure: Why is this happening?
Shure:  你们导师好啊
Shure: Your mentor is good.
Jake: 导师确实
Jake: The mentor is indeed...
其他人： 只有只有好的老师才会照最强的人
Others: Only good teachers take care of the strongest students.
Shure:  别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Shure:  明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be a staff member.
Shure:  哈哈你快去山东进修两年吧
Shure: Haha, you'd better go to Shandong for further studies for two years.
Alice: 哈哈山东
Alice: Haha, Shandong.
Shure:  山东
Shure: Shandong.
其他人：越来越夸张了
Others: It's getting more and more exaggerated.
Shure:  我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I don't want even one more point.
Shure:  他只要给我60就行
Shure: Just give me 60, that's fine.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why do you need 90 points?
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He scored 90 points.
Lucia: 嗯哦
Lucia: Hmm, oh
Tasha: 我还以为
Tasha: I thought...
Shure:  我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said I just need 60 points.
Shure:  你多一分都是多给我的都没有用
Shure: Any extra points you give me are useless.
其他人：你企战是60吗
Others: Did you aim for 60?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：企战
Others: Aim for 60?
Shure:  企战是什么
Shure: What does "aim for 60" mean?
Jake: 企业战略我都记得啊
Jake: Corporate strategy, I remember it all.
Shure:  不是应该不是60
Shure: No, it shouldn't be 60.
其他人：我整整60分
Others: I got exactly 60 points.
其他人：我跟你们说我就是我
Others: I'm telling you, I'm just...
其他人：考试非常想提前交卷嘛
Others: I really wanted to hand in the exam early.
其他人：这考试这考这些
Others: This exam, these questions...
其他人：我实在真的不
Others: I really don't...
其他人：会然后我本来是有时间复习的
Others: know, and I actually had time to review.
其他人： 但那段时间繁华太好了
Others: But that period was so exciting.
其他人：我一直在看繁华
Others: I kept watching the excitement.
其他人： 所以那个真的没复习
Others: So, I really didn't review.
Shure:  我带他看哈哈哈
Shure: I was watching it with him, haha.
其他人：我在那看
Others: I was watching it.
其他人：哈哈哈然后考试的时候
Others: Haha, then during the exam...
其他人：我三三十多分的交卷
Others: I handed in my paper with just thirty something points.
Jake:你差不多
Jake: That sounds about right.
其他人：因为我一堂课没
Others: Because I didn't attend any classes...
其他人：因为我一堂课没有去过
Others: Because I never attended a single class.
其他人：所以我不知道老师长什么样
Others: So, I didn't know what the teacher looked like.
其他人： 其实那个监考老师就是我们的老师
Others: Actually, the proctor was our teacher.
Tasha: 但是我不知道
Tasha: But I didn't know that.
其他人：我以为他只是个小小学生
Others: I thought he was just a little student.
Lucia: 小学生小学生真是
Lucia: A little student, really?
其他人：我就直接我就直接教了
Others: I just handed it in right away.
其他人：交了之后还是他跟我说的
Others: After handing it in, he told me...
Shure:  老师在这阴阳怪气的
Shure: The teacher was so sarcastic.
Shure:  我拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: I took his paper and told you...
Shure:  就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: Those who hand in this early...
Shure:  一字不写的
Shure: without writing a word...
Shure:  不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: No, no, writing just a few words...
Shure:  这肯肯定过不了
Shure: They definitely won't pass.
Shure:  那肯必须挂他
Shure: They will definitely fail.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: So in the end, you didn't fail.
其他人：只能说老师人太好了
Others: You could say the teacher was too nice.
其他人：可能看我写的屁话太多了
Others: Maybe they saw all the nonsense I wrote.
Shure:  不不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: And then after he said that, I just added two words.
Shure:  我就咔就笑了哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: I just burst out laughing, hahaha!
其他人：然后我来把这个把这个荷包传给我
Others: And then I got this pouch passed to me.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to quickly tell him the good news.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
其他人：然后整个寒假都没过好
Others: And then the whole winter break was ruined.
其他人：感觉我们俩傻逼了
Others: Felt like we were idiots.
Jake: 学了一个
Jake: Learned something.
Jake: 喊他起人哈哈哈
Jake: Call him up, hahaha.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Jake: 哈哈哈单身可以
Jake: Hahaha, single is okay.
Shure:  他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure:  我还有一门课
Shure: I have another class.
Shure:  因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: Because I missed a quiz once.
Shure:  就是平时小测
Shure: Just a small quiz.
Shure:  然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: And that day I had something for my internship.
Shure:  然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the teacher.
Shure:  我说平时分
Shure: I said, my usual grade...
Shure:  咱那个没过
Shure: Didn't pass, but my total score did, can I pass?
Shure:  但是我总成绩过了能不能给我过
Shure: And he said, yes.
Shure:  他说可以的
Shure: But in the end, he failed me.
Shure:  然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure: And made me retake it.
Shure:  然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: Just the small quiz.
Shure:  平时小测
Shure: It was so humiliating.
Shure:  唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: You know?
Shure:  你知道吗
其他人：有两门吗
Others: There were two classes?
其他人：我觉得有
Others: I think so.
其他人：有一门平时无所谓
Others: One where usual grades didn't matter.
其他人：有一门平时不行
Others: And one where they did.
Shure:  唉我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, it wasn't what he personally promised.
Shure:  然后最后搞这种
Shure: And in the end, he did this.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Ugh.
Jake: 走吧换眼镜
Jake: Let's go change glasses.
Shure:  好disconnect finish
Shure: Okay, disconnect finished.
Shure:  完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have the finish button again.
Alice: 我也是哦
Alice: Me neither.
Alice: 好了
Alice: Got it.
Shure:  connecting oh okay
Shure: Connecting... oh, okay.
Tasha: complete recording
Tasha: Complete recording.
Shure:  这段时间
Shure: During this time...